[Musica]
avrete già capito a questo punto che
abbiamo alcuni problemi e che ci sono
persone che si impegnano molto per per
risolverli abbiamo sentito claudio
abbiamo sentito già diverse soluzioni
però io vorrei parlarvi di un problema
che stranamente continua a rimanere
sommerso e di cui non sentiamo parlare
quasi mai che sta diventando però molto
centrale e divagando velocemente quello
che diceva andrea prima noi dodici anni
fa qui stavamo cercando di fare le
comunità energetiche che adesso claudia
sta faticosamente cercando di fare
partire e abbiamo improvvisamente
scoperto che era impossibile perché era
proprio vietato dalla legge
ci sono voluti dodici anni per arrivare
ad oggi è avere una normativa europea
non ha ancora completamente recepita dal
nostro paese per cui adesso claudia è lì
che lei è molto gentile ovviamente
politicamente corretta lo dico io per
lei non è che stia facendo un lavoro
facile perché si deve inventare un sacco
di cose che ancora non ci sono
questo è il problema il problema è se
abbiamo dei problemi così gravi così
importanti perché non stiamo facendo
niente di veramente sostanziale per
risolverli e io volevo parlarvi appunto
di questo che è una cosa molto strana e
particolare
facciamo riassunto delle puntate
precedenti da quando abbiamo capito che
era assolutamente vitale indispensabile
ridurre le emissioni climalteranti in
atmosfera
perché stavamo rischiando grossissimo le
abbiamo aumentate del 60 per cento
non va tanto bene poi non è che finisca
qui perché siamo ci dicono gli
scienziati entrati in questo periodo che
si chiama la sesta estinzione di massa
chi è che si estingue un po tutti
compresi noi
a un certo punto nel senso che magari
noi arriveremo un po più avanti e
intanto si estinguono altri animali
insetti di vario tipo poi tocca a noi
se non aveste mai esplorato con cadono
all'argomento c'è questo magnifico libro
di elizabeth kolberth che ha vinto pure
un pulitzer
facendo questa opera divulgativa quindi
magari andate a fare una esplorazione
quindi riscaldamento globale si stanno
estinguendo bene fino qui forse queste
cose le avete sentite non è finita lì
esiste questo studio che è uno studio di
riferimento per tutti quelli che si
occupano di sostenibilità però non è
tanto diffuso invece tra i non addetti
ai lavori
si chiama planetary boundaries e prende
in considerazione una serie di fattori
che vengono ritenuti assolutamente
indispensabili per la sopravvivenza
della civiltà umana e di tutte le altre
specie su questo pianeta
nelle condizioni attuali questo è quello
che servirebbe per conservare il sistema
mondo in uno stato di stabilità questi
scienziati hanno cominciato a misurare
la situazione di questi vari elementi e
potete vedere molto rapidamente non so
se vedete ma ve lo riassumo io ci sono
tre fattori fondamentali totalmente
fuori scala allarme rosso disperazione
che sono appunto la biodiversità e il
ciclo dei ritratti e del fosforo
lo sapevate quelli sono alla
disperazione più totale ci sono un altro
paio di fattori che sono il cambiamento
d'uso del suolo e appunto il
riscaldamento globale che sono in stato
di emergenza
ci sono altri fattori che sono più o
meno sotto controllo e poi ci sono
addirittura tre fattori considerati
fondamentali di cui non sappiamo nulla
quindi quando sono andati a cercare i
dati hanno detto non abbiamo i dati non
sappiamo cosa dire rispetto a questa
cosa potrebbe essere tutto tranquillo
potrebbe essere un dramma
allora la domanda è perché cioè come
succede che siamo in una situazione così
grave
innanzitutto poco conosciuta e
continuiamo a reagire come se non stesse
succedendo niente le cose meravigliose
che vi hanno raccontato fino adesso
vanno benissimo ma non sono nella
parla di questo tipo di problemi abbiamo
bisogno di agire in un modo
infinitamente più veloce quella legge
che abbiamo avuto in 12 anni e voglio
fare più un tributo a dario tamburrano
che casualmente è uno dei fondatori
tradizioni italia che ha lavorato 5 anni
il parlamento europeo con altri colleghi
per farla approvare e che gli è costata
l'esaurimento nervoso lacrime sangue
capite ci abbiamo messo 12 anni per
arrivare alla situazione in cui ancora
non riusciamo nemmeno ad adottarla per
bene allora dovremmo cominciare a
concentrarci su qualcosa di diverso per
esempio ci abbiamo messo abbiamo fatto
21 conferenza dei servizi per arrivare
all'accordo di parigi
no abbiamo passato 21 anni e dissi ma
cosa facciamo
ma facciamo che ci rivediamo quest'altra
anno e poi decidiamo qualcosa e poi
abbiamo fatto l'accordo di parigi che è
un accordo che per carità è meglio di
niente ma è assolutamente insufficiente
rispetto agli obiettivi che abbiamo
allora questo è un po il mistero
da tempo gli scienziati che si occupano
di sostenibilità ci stanno dicendo in un
modo molto molto esplicito che i nostri
sistemi decisionali non sono adatti a
risolvere i problemi che abbiamo
cioè non funzionano non sono
sufficientemente potenti per fare le
cose che ci servono e ce lo dicono da un
pezzo questo jorge randers 1 gli
estensori del dello studio sui limiti
della crescita degli anni 70 che ha
passato la vita a raccontare questa cosa
allora il mercato può regolare queste
cose no la politica nel nostro sistema
democratico riesce
no non riesce e questo è un problema che
ancora stranamente rimane oscuro
inesplorato nessuno se ne sta
preoccupando in modo serio
allora la democrazia rappresentativa non
ce la fa non riesce ad affrontare questo
problema ed è semplice capire perché
perché chiunque proponga di fare le cose
che servono e oggi servono cose
estremamente incisive difficilmente
viene eletto no perché sono cose che in
prima battuta vengono vissute come
punitiva devo rinunciare a qualche cosa
quindi quel sistema non funziona però
nel frattempo studiando capendo tanto
della democrazia perché c'è una vasta
area dell'accademia che studia queste
cose che c'è una vasta area della
pratica abbiamo scoperto che cambiando
il metodo democratico
cambiano le decisioni che vengono prese
cioè lo stesso gruppo di persone uguale
messo nelle condizioni di decidere con
un meccanismo diverso prende decisioni
completamente diverse
e se posso dire se voi poteste allungare
il collo e vedere la scuola che sia
dall'altra parte di questa di questo
splendido edificio è una scuola che è
completamente autonoma energeticamente
regola il flusso dell'aria non è
collegata al al gas metano alla rete del
gas metano è stata fatta tanto tempo fa
è stata fatta nel mondo reale da un
sindaco reale che qui come è strano
avere una scuola di questo tipo e non
vederla riprodotta mille volte altrove è
rimasta la sola nessuno l'ha rifatta una
scuola come questi costa come le altre
perché qui è stata fatta in un altro
posto e quindi un po la cosa che vi devo
dire
a quel tempo lavoravamo in modo molto
istintivo non conoscevamo le teorie che
stavano dietro questo modo di fare
democrazia che continuiamo a chiamarla
così
eppure io vi dico che si può fare se
volessimo potremmo farsi spiegare oggi
dai neuroscienziati vi consiglio
tantissimo sa boschi e il suo libro
perché è utilissimo per capire come
funzionano davvero i nostri cervelli
probabilmente dovrei dire come
non funzionano i nostri cervelli perché
il progresso un po questo funzionano
così un po a tentoni ci potrebbe
spiegare molto bene perché facciamo così
fatica a prendere delle decisioni che
dovrebbero essere normali cioè una una
civiltà che si sta estinguendo darebbe
dirà forse sarebbe meglio non
estinguersi
non sembra un ragionamento così
complicato eppure non lo facciamo però
io vi parlo più da attivista io ho
passato gli ultimi 12 anni della mia
vita a sperimentare queste cose qui è in
giro per il mondo in contesti molto
diversi gli uni dagli altri
all'inizio in modo molto istintivo poi
pian piano abbiamo imparato ci hanno
aiutato alle università i ricercatori
abbiamo capito molto di più e oggi sono
qui per dirvi che c'è un come è un come
molto preciso che si può far funzionare
qui e subito
e basterebbe volerlo allora vi faccio
vedere due strumenti perché è quello che
vorrei fare con voi oggi e aprirmi
semplicemente le finestre su una
dimensione che magari non conoscete il
primo democrazia deliberativa viene già
usata molto spesso in tutto il mondo è
un meccanismo che fa prendere le
decisioni invece che a una a un gruppo
di politici eletti a un gruppo di
manager per prendere le decisioni a un
gruppo di cittadini sorteggiati in modo
statisticamente stratificato si dice
cioè viene costruito un gruppo che
rappresenta diciamo così la popolazione
questo gruppo viene lasciato lavorare
viene informato da tutti gli esperti che
sono a disposizione passa del tempo a
capire il quesito al quale bisogna
prendere una decisione e una volta fatto
questo prende una decisione finale o
costruisce un consiglio per chi poi dopo
deve far rendere attuativa la decisione
finale
sembra strano ma questa formula funziona
infinitamente meglio quando l'obiettivo
è il bene comune quando l'obiettivo è
raggiungere qualcosa tutti assieme
funziona infinitamente meglio dei
meccanismi che usiamo
adesso è un gruppo molto più potente nel
prendere decisioni ci sono dei movimenti
in questo momento che stanno spingendo
molto questa logica perché
effettivamente è uno strumento molto
potente è uno strumento che qui per
esempio abbiamo usato durante la fusione
dei comuni valsamoggia un comune nuovo
fusione di cinque comuni c'è stato un
referendum e il quesito referendario è
stato analizzato ed è stato costruito un
parere dai cittadini prima del
referendum utilizzando questa
metodologia se voi andate a vedere il
documento che ha prodotto quel gruppo di
cittadini scoprireste che erano stati
meravigliosi nel capire tutti gli
aspetti positivi e tutti gli aspetti
critici di questa cosa e avranno
costruito un documento di una qualità
informativa e grecia queste cose si
possono fare subito qui non serve niente
si prende e si fa il problema della
democrazia deliberativa e che è un po
costosa e serve molto tempo per cui
bisogna capire bene quando utilizzarla
va bene per decisioni grandi importanti
non va tanto bene per gestire il
quotidiano vi faccio vedere invece
un'altra cosa che viene dal mondo della
società razzia anche questo non è un
mondo nuovo sì faccio so krazia da un
centinaio di anni almeno
ed è uno strumento che era poi
rapidissima diffusione in tutto il mondo
perché in tutto il mondo si percepisce
questa necessità di strumenti per
prendere decisioni che siano molto più
efficaci di quelli che usiamo
normalmente e che ci portino a prendere
decisioni che sono diverse da quelle che
continuiamo a prendere in modo sbagliato
in particolare l'ultima versione che c'è
questo non è un po buffo socio krazia
3.0 sembra un po un software un
programma o anche s3 è uno strumento
incredibilmente flessibile
interessantissimo potentissimo e anche
questo per esempio lo stiamo usando qui
e in altri posti del mondo però per
esempio in valsamoggia viene utilizzato
all'interno del nostro sistema
amministrativo sia in un progetto che si
chiama municipale in transition sia nel
tavolo di emergenza climatica che la
valsamoggia ha costituito
e perché è così interessante perché ci
apre delle dimensioni totalmente nuove e
molto goduriose il socio krazia si
procede quando non ci sono più ragioni
per non procedere non si vota a
maggioranza si analizza una proposta si
fanno emergere le eventuali obiezioni
questa proposta e si va avanti se non ci
sono ragioni per non andare avanti è
molto difficile capire quanto
rivoluzionario sia questo modo di
procedere
finché non provate non vi rendete conto
del salto quantico che si fa cambiando
in e muovendosi in questa dimensione ma
vi assicuro che è impressionante
qui tra voi c'è gente che la usa dopo
magari chiedere un po alle impressioni
perché fa veramente tanta differenza ma
guardate le cose più interessanti in
socio krazia chiunque è toccato da una
decisione ha diritto di partecipare al
processo decisionale
quindi è totalmente inclusiva non si può
mai lasciare indietro nessuno non c'è
nessun modo di lasciare indietro
qualcuno in società ma è ancora più
bello di così perché a quel punto
siccome il processo è inverso la
diversità del gruppo cioè il fatto di
avere nel gruppo anche quello che ti sta
antipatico il tuo peggior nemico
l'opposizione diventa un benefit per il
gruppo e quindi in realtà lo vai a
cercare perché più il gruppo è diverso
più la decisione aumenta
qualitativamente e più aumenta la
sicurezza della decisione e all'inizio
molto difficile da capire ma mano a mano
che la si usa e si capisce che funziona
davvero così diventa assolutamente
indispensabile avere nel gruppo quello
che normalmente lasceresti fuori perché
no quello mi disturba questi qui sono
sono dell'altro partito sono dell'altra
sponda sono dell'altro esercito
e infine si riesce attraverso questa
metodologia a realizzare questa cosa
straordinaria si può far partecipare al
processo decisionale anche gli
ecosistemi le piante gli alberi il
terreno ed è una cosa che anche l'onu ha
cominciato a spingere da questo punto di
vista perché sapete che ci sono ormai
fiumi che hanno personalità giuridica no
perché non sappiamo più come fare a
difendere questi elementi e in questi
processi si può effettivamente
introdurre molto facilmente questo
elemento bene gli strumenti ce li
abbiamo
rimane solo questo ma vogliamo cambiare
effettivamente ci piace estinguersi
perché di devo dire la verità io
incontro tantissima gente che mi dice no
ma distinguiamo c no perché alla fine
dai the siamo cioè siamo un disastro
facciamo non capiamo niente
facciamo così estinguiamo mi sembra la
cosa più bella
quindi se siete di quella parte lì vabbè
ci estinguiamo se per caso vi è rimasta
un po di bahia invece di inventarvi
un'altra storia siano forse la nome
trasale nell'uomo in cui si potrebbe
effettivamente fare che abbiamo tutto
quello che serve
abbiamo gli strumenti e allora il mio
invito è esplorate queste cose chiedete
di impararle provate a inserirle nella
vostra vita e soprattutto dotiamo le
generazioni più giovani di questi
strumenti perché qualunque sia il futuro
che si attende che ci attende sarà un
futuro
incredibilmente complicato e sarà molto
facile scivolare in totalitarismi e cose
di questo tipo servono strumenti di
questo tipo sarebbe bello vedere
l'umanità evolversi
da quel punto di vista è secondo me la
cosa ancora più bella è che si può fare
[Applauso]